right just waiting for twitch to say the
stream is live and it looks like
now the stream is live so let's jump in
wow end of week seven it's moving fast
at this point uh so before we uh before
we get into the um
the material for today uh i want to take
just a moment at the beginning of class
to
talk about some uh administrative stuff
and we'll talk about where we're headed
for the rest of the quarter
and then we'll get into the the meat of
today
so today we're going to be talking about
something
totally new
we're going to talk about eventual
consistency
we're going to talk about strong
convergence whoops
and strong eventual consistency
we're going to be talking about
application specific
conflict resolution
and
network partitions
availability
and that'll lead us into talking about
cap the cap trade-off
one of the most famous trade-offs in
distributed systems
so uh administrative stuff first
so we're getting to that point now in
the in the
quarter where the deadlines are coming
at you fast and furious
so as you know uh programming assignment
has been out for a couple of weeks and
it's due
a week from tomorrow so by now your
group should have been
um should have made some serious
progress on
the third assignment if you don't feel
like you've made some serious progress
yet
uh now is the time to really start
working on it
because that deadline is going to come
up faster than you think
it's especially going to come up faster
than you think because
we have a between then and now we have a
reading assignment so i'm asking you to
read a paper the first reading
assignment that we've had
for this course uh is uh is for next
tuesday and i'm asking you to read the
amazon dynamo paper
which is linked here from our course
website so you can go
and check that out um if you
were looking at this page a couple of
weeks ago it was a broken link so
sorry about that but now the paper is
hosted locally so the link should work
fine
so before next tuesday uh you should
read that paper and actually some of
what we talk about today
is going to give you the foundation that
you need to understand the key ideas of
the paper
i would budget a bunch of time for this
um
especially if you're not used to reading
academic research papers
budget something like several hours to
read this paper
and do understand that you don't need to
understand every detail
but i want you to be sure to take a good
look at it before
next week before next week's uh first
lecture
oh and then by the way as long as i'm
looking at this page i might as well
mention
so we have the mid-course survey which
should have been due
on tuesday but then i got a couple of uh
panicked messages from people
who said that they didn't fill it out in
time and could i open it up again so
that they could fill it out so i
reopened the mid-course survey
which by the way you get a few points
for doing so
if it's not enough of a motivation to
you to just
do it because it's a good idea to kind
of look at how you're doing kind of
consider how you're doing in the course
and think about it
um as if that's not enough motivation
you're also getting a little bit of
course credit for it so
if you haven't yet filled out the
midcourse survey please do so
uh it's still open and i'll close it
later tonight which is two days later
than i said i was going to close it so
i'm
giving some extra time for you
stragglers who haven't done it yet
any questions about schedule type stuff
or what's coming up
oh and as long as i'm talking about this
i might as well mention we also have a
guest speaker
coming up on the 25th
we will have the honor of having cyrus
hall
who is formerly of twitch and amazon web
services
to talk to us about practical
distributed systems design
and i'm really excited about this
usually every year i try to get some
people from industry and cyrus
is somebody that patrick introduced me
to
and so i'm really looking forward to
this talk and
he's given me a little bit of a preview
of what it'll be about and i think it'll
be great
so i think you'll like it too
so that's coming up on tuesday the the
25th
all right doesn't look like anybody has
any questions about any of that
so let's jump into today's material
so um
so we've been talking about consistency
uh
in particular we've been talking about
strong consistency
uh for a few days we talked about how
you could use primary backup replication
or chain replication to get strong
consistency among replicas
uh then we talked about how how strong
consistency ultimately relies on
consensus
and i you know i really want to
emphasize this
if you want to have strong consistency
sooner or later
uh you you and and the key thing is if
you if you
if you want to have strong consistency
and you also want to tolerate
nodes failing uh
i should say if you want it to be
fault-tolerant
so if you want fall tolerance which you
do because faults happen
then you need to have some kind of
consensus mechanism sooner or later
uh so the trouble with strong
consistency is that it's hard to enforce
uh and i was just talking about this
with somebody in office hours a little
while ago
so there was if you recall there was a
question on the midterm
that had to do with kind of our standard
total order anomaly
example that we've seen so so many times
and the question said okay what if you
had something like this
and you tried to use vector clocks
to solve this problem so the issue here
is that these messages are arriving in
different orders on these different
replicas
and the question was could you use
vector clocks to solve this problem
and the answer is no you cannot use
vector clocks to solve this
um so here's what would happen if you
tried to use vector clocks here
um and i have to apologize to the
student who i
i tried to do this in office hours like
a little while ago just off the top of
my head
and i think i got the vector clocks
wrong um
because i'm a human not a computer and
computers are better at vector clocks
than humans are but let's try to do it
and actually get it right this time okay
so let's try to assign
vector clocks to all the events in this
execution so like this one would be like
one zero zero
zero um and this is the original vector
clocks algorithm that we talked about
where every event in here
counts so r1 would get the
message here and so we count the receive
as an event and so we do like this
similarly here so all i'm trying to do
here is look at this execution
and try to assign vector clocks to to
events
so i can determine the order of events
um and so this message would get here
so at this point the um
the vector clock on the process is one
zero zero one
um that could get merged with this one
and then we increment one for the
receive so it would be like one two zero
one
similarly over here 1 0 0 1 is the vc on
the process
and that would get merged with this one
here so we'd get something like
1 0 2 1.
so all i'm doing now is assigning vector
clocks to events
here's my question for you what would
happen uh
so i've i've put these vector clocks
here on these two events
um do these events have an order
according to their vector clocks what
happens if we compare those two vector
clocks is one of them bigger
no that's right neither one is bigger so
these two events are causally
independent
so causality tells us nothing about how
to order those events
but as we've talked about before what if
these messages were doing something like
assigning uh values to keys in a key
value store
then at this point this replica would
think that x was 3
right because it got that message second
this replica would think that x is 4
because it got that message second so
even if you had a causal consistency
you could still have concurrent updates
like this that would leave these two
replicas
differing and by the way this could
happen
in the causally consistent key value
store that you all are implementing for
the homework so you could have exactly
this problem where these replicas end up
differing
because the issue here was not an issue
of um
of violation of causal consistency
causal consistency is being respected
here the issue is
is something else the issue is a
violation of totally ordered delivery so
what do you do
what can you do about this you want your
replicas to be consistent right
well one option would be to run a
consensus protocol
right like we've been talking about
to get these replicas to agree but
as we have seen consensus is expensive
it requires sending a lot of messages
and it might not even terminate
so there's a lot of reasons not to do
consensus
so what i would much rather do
is avoid having to use consensus and if
you think back to
a few days ago when i gave a whole list
of problems
where i said that solving those problems
required consensus whether it's a
problem of
totally ordered broadcast like this or
the problem of
distributed transaction commit or the
problem of leader election
or the problem of distributed mutual
exclusion all those things
i said that all you need consensus for
all those things
but the same issue applies in all those
situations where consensus is hard to do
so quite often what you actually want to
do to solve those problems
is try to find a way to get around the
problem
so that you don't actually need
consensus
so in this case in particular what i
would really like to do instead of
having to use consensus to get these
replicas to agree because that sounds
hard and painful and might not terminate
and would take a lot of messages and be
slow
instead of doing that what i would
really like to do is find some sort of
way to make it so that the order in
which these updates arrived at these
replicas
doesn't matter and often
that's the right thing to do because
often the order in which updates arrive
doesn't actually matter very much
so you tell me what is an example of a
situation in which the order of two
updates wouldn't matter
what are what are two updates where you
don't care what order they happen in
okay so the the response here was get
requests so
okay um uh so the the
i think that's not quite the answer i
was looking for because get requests
aren't updates
right so what's an example of an update
what would be an example of a of a put
request where the order still doesn't
matter
okay so here's somebody else in chat is
suggesting something really good which
is if we're updating two different keys
it shouldn't matter yeah okay so what if
we what if we had um
our two clients um
but just like before
let's say that these messages arrived
like so
but let's say that um client one
was updating the key x
and client two was updating uh the q
the key y so what would you end up with
then well
you can think of the state of these two
replicas
as being a sort of set of all the key
value pairs
right so on replica one
at this point you would just have one
item in that set
you'd have the entry that says that x is
four and similarly over here you'd have
this entry
and then down here after the second
update arrived
now there would be another element in
your set right
so i've written the elements of the set
in different orders
um but that doesn't matter because sets
are unordered so this and this are equal
and so if different keys are being
updated by these different rights
then i don't really care that the
updates land in different orders because
they end up being in this the replicas
end up being in the same state
eventually
i at least don't care very much now
so let's say that we did this let's say
that we have a situation like this where
these replicas end up in the same state
once the updates have arrived on
on both the replicas would this give you
strong consistency
so is this strong consistency in this
picture
recall what strong consistency means uh
which is strong consistency means that
clients can't tell the data is
replicated
oh a student just asked a question they
asked uh what kind of vector clock is
being used in this diagram on top so
if you remember back to um when we first
talked about vector clocks we talked
about
uh using vector clocks to assign
uh we we talked about assigning a
a vector clock to every event in an
execution and so
everything's being counted here sends
are being counted and receives are being
counted
so in this case i wasn't trying to use
our causal broadcast algorithm which
only counts sends
although that would have been um i could
have done that too right like if we were
just to looking at
at these two sends these are the vector
clocks of the sense right
and you can tell looking at those the
vector clocks of just the sends
those are also concurrent so you can see
that these two messages are being sent
concurrently
and so that means that these messages uh
don't have an order
okay so back to my question here so in
this picture on the bottom
where my replicas you know they look
different for a little while and then
later
at the end they looked if they look the
same is this strong consistency in this
picture on the bottom what do you think
no it's not why not
what makes this not strong consistency
okay so somebody is saying something in
chat about linearizable order yeah okay
but i think we can answer this question
even by using our informal definition of
strong consistency
which has to do with what clients can
tell so
yeah so great answer in chat which is
that
a client can read data during this point
right here before they both arrive at
the same state a client could come along
and read here and then come along and
read here
and see that the replicas differ so the
client would be able to tell
that the data is being replicated and
that violates what we want strong
consistency to mean we want it to mean
that clients can't tell that the data is
replicated
so this is not strong consistency
but it still seems better than this
situation that we were in up here
where the replicas were both updating x
and the replicas ended up different
right so at least here the replicas
eventually agreed
right so it's not strong consistency
but nevertheless the replicas end up
agreeing in this execution
so we can give a name to this property
it turns out
it's called eventual consistency
so informally we can define eventual
consistency
as follows we can say replicas
eventually agree
if clients stop submitting updates
so eventual consistency means that
if clients stop submitting updates the
replicas will eventually come to agree
what kind of property does eventual
consistency look like to you does it
look like it's a
safety property or does it look like
it's a liveness property
good yeah it's a liveness property
how can you tell well that fact that it
has the word eventual in it
is a big big hint right so it's a
property that cannot be violated in a
finite execution remember we said
liveness properties are those that
can't be violated in a finite execution
so in this example here that we had a
second ago
um like this one up here
right where one replica ended up with x
is three and one ended up with x is four
you could still satisfy eventual
consistency here if you implemented some
mechanism that made these replicas agree
right which would probably involve them
sending more messages
but eventual consistency hasn't been
violated in this execution up here
really it just hasn't been satisfied yet
you could still make this execution
eventual consistent
this one here already is eventually
consistent
so eventual consistency is aliveness
property
good so this means that
if you think about all those consistency
models that we talked about before
where we talked about like read your
rights
and we talked about like fifo
and causal
and strong
these were all safety properties
i should say consistency guarantees
are safety properties
they're all things that can be violated
in a finite execution
so eventual consistency really doesn't
belong in the same category as any of
those other
consistency guarantees that we talked
about it's really confusing
it's a really confusing name because it
has the word consistency
right here so you might think that it
belongs in the same category as all
these other consistency guarantees
um but i would argue that it doesn't
belong in that category
because with eventual consistency you
can't write down
a finite execution where it's been
violated you can only write down
an execution where it hasn't been
satisfied yet
so really i couldn't really put eventual
consistency in this picture anywhere
so it really belongs it's it's whole
it's its own whole separate thing
and this is something that i think
people get confused about a lot
so eventual consistency is really its
own
separate property that shouldn't be
considered in the same
hierarchy as these other properties
but there actually is a safety property
that we could write down that
distinguishes between these two
executions here
so i would like to try to express the
difference between this and this
in a safety property and it turns out
that you can do that
so the safety property that i want to
use there
is called
strong convergence
so this one is a safety property
strong convergence says
replicas that
have delivered the same
set
of updates
have equivalent state
so the set here is the keyword
i didn't say that the updates had to
come in the same order
just that they have to have gotten the
same set of updates
so this actually is a property this is a
safety property that you can use to
distinguish between
these two executions up here
so this one here the executions have
gotten the same set of updates in
different orders
but their states differ so this one
violates
strong convergence
but this one down here satisfies strong
convergence
so sometimes you'll hear people talk
about
a combination so i said down here that
this execution here
um shows us an example of eventual
consistency and i'm also saying
that it satisfies strong convergence so
sometimes you'll hear people talk about
those two properties kind of rolled into
one
and you'll hear about a system that has
strong
eventual
consistency
and by strong eventual consistency they
mean
both eventual consistency and strong
convergence
so strong eventual consistency is a
combination of the two
and notice it's a combination of a
liveness property and a safety property
so
every property is either a liveness
property or a safety property or a
combination of the two
so strong eventual consistency is an
example of a a property that's one of
those fun ones that's a mix of safety
and liveness
so the eventual consistency piece is the
is the liveness piece
strong convergence is the safety piece
questions about any of that
so
as i mentioned a little while ago um
you're going to be reading the dynamo
paper
uh for next week and this is one of the
most well-known
distributed systems papers of
this century i would say so
it's among the most highly cited it's
incredibly influential blah blah blah
blah blah
and so we're going to read it and we're
going to talk about it and so
what we're doing today is trying to
introduce some concepts that i think
will be useful to have in mind
as you talk about so eventual
consistency is one of those concepts and
um so the dynamo paper doesn't use this
term
that i just introduced a strong
convergence that actually came later
so there were some researchers who did
later work
that was sort of a formalization of what
the diam dynamo people were doing
uh in in practice and
they gave this term a strong convergence
uh to it
so but that wasn't a term that the
dynamo people use so strong convergence
strong eventual consistency
that isn't terminology that you're going
to find a newspaper
but i think eventual consistency is they
do talk about that
uh so coming back to this example
we sort of cheated a little bit right
because
when we were talking about an execution
that would give you strong convergence
we cheated in that our two clients in
this example were
updating different keys so that seems
like a really
really easy way to get strong
convergence right
like if we're updating different keys
and then we end up with this state where
each replica's state is just sort of a
set of key value pairs
there's nothing hard about that right
like there's there's really
nothing too interesting there
so what if we made it harder
can anybody think of a way that we could
still
have strong convergence that would still
involve both clients writing to the same
key
any ideas how could we let both clients
write to x
and still have strong convergence
hmm suggestion in chat is periodically
reset to a value
hmm i'm not really sure what that would
mean
let's make it concrete let's say that
these let's change this this
y to an x here well okay at this point
we just have
x is four over here
and at this point we have x is three
what if i just change all my y's to x's
here
what if i have something like that or
maybe an easier way to write it is like
this
whoops
okay so what did i do here
well this replica uh
r1 uh applied to the right
it said x to four and then when the
other update came in to sit x to three
it can look at its causal history see
that this write is concurrent
right because the vector clock on here
as we talked about a little while ago
the vector clock on this message makes
it concurrent with that other one
it can see that this write is concurrent
and then it can just save that value of
x also
and replica r2 can do the same thing in
the other order first it'll set
x to three and then later this other
update will come along and say oh well
there's a concurrent update x i'll just
save that one too
looks like strong convergence to me
right
the trouble now though of course is that
a client that's trying to do a read is
going to get both
values right so what is the client going
to do well
clients going to have to figure out what
they want to do
right they're going to see that there
have been concurrent updates to x
and when they try to read acts they're
going to have to do any conflict
resolution themselves
how do they resolve the conflict well
we can't tell them what to do the
appropriate way to resolve the conflict
is going to have to def depend on the
application
but we do have strong convergence
because the replicas do indeed have the
same state
after delivering the same set of updates
so there's just a question chat with
which is so we keep a log of different
values for the same key
uh yeah pretty much except i wouldn't
necessarily use the word log because
if you're calling it a log that implies
a sort of temporal order
right when i think of a log i think of
things have first one thing happening
and then the next thing happening and
then the next thing happening
and the whole point here is that these
two updates were in fact concurrent
so what we're finding out here like if
these
updates weren't concurrent then they
wouldn't have to both be stored because
if replica one could tell
that these updates weren't concurrent
then it would know that they had a
causal order
and then it would say okay well i'll
just apply whichever one is causally
uh last last and similarly on replica
two it would apply whichever one is
causally second
second um but in this case we don't have
such a causal order so
uh so it's not so much that we're
keeping a log of different values it's
just that we're keeping a set
of different values an unordered set of
the same value
of different values um so we have strong
convergence
because the replicas have the same state
but now we've kind of offloaded the
problem to the client
right because the client coming along at
this point let's say this client
client two after having done her right
of x is three let's say she does a read
now
right here so she's asking what is x
and she gets back the response
four and three
uh does it satisfy read your rights well
sure because
yeah she's reading her own right of
three
so read your rights is is fine here
kinda but then there's this other value
for x that
um that apparently came in concurrently
that she's now finding out about
so we're really offloading the problem
to the client
saying well we have these concurrent
updates you figure it out
so now it's the client's job to kind of
do more work here
so here's our client kind of scratching
her head about what to do next because
the the data store has not answered this
problem for her she now has to figure
out on herself
it's now on her to try to solve this
problem
so let me give you an example of
application specific
conflict resolution that is deeply
important
to amazon so let's say
that our replicas r1 and r2
are both storing my shopping cart
and let's say that client one
and client two
um are both adding things to the cart
so
let's say that client one is um is my
laptop
and i want to add a book to the shopping
cart
so i send a message saying that i want
to add a book
and let's say that it lands like that on
the replicas
so here's the book that i'm adding
and meanwhile uh client two is my phone
and
let's say that i want to buy a blender
so i add the blender to my cart
okay so then what happens
well book gets added here here's a set
representing the contents of my cart
so now a client does a read to ask what
my card is and by the way the clients in
this case
i don't necessarily mean that they're me
like me the human being
rather this client could be some system
within
amazon that's using a data storage
service within amazon
so this client is not necessarily me
with my web browser or me with my phone
but this client here could be thought of
as some process that's maybe also
running in the amazon data center
that's now submitting you know my
client request as a human being uh to
the data store
okay so at this point
the book has arrived on replica 2. so
now we've got something here that's like
uh we've got a set containing a book
and we've also got a set containing a
blender
so two sets similarly over here
we've got the book and the blender
why do they both have to be sets well
they're sets because
every client thinks of the shopping cart
as a set right like this client over
here could also add another book and
then we would have
a set with two elements um so
okay so really this is like a set of
sets here where we've got two
sets each representing a shopping cart
now a client does a read to find out
what the contents of the card is
so the client is asking what's in the
cart
and they get back this set of sets that
says
there's one cart containing a book
and there's one cart containing a
blender
i hope you like my art my very
sophisticated drawings
so the client has now gotten two values
back from their query about what's in
the cart they've gotten two copies of a
cart
so the first one is a book and the
second one is is a blender what do you
think the client should do to resolve
that conflict
uh good question in chat so that
somebody asks yeah with shopping carts
we could have duplicates yeah so
wouldn't it be like a multi-set yeah
so yeah in practice you could have a
quantity of items that you're adding
right so
that's that's a simplification that i'm
making here i'm pretending that
every item in the store is something
that can only be added once but yeah
in practice um you would have uh it
would
it would be something like a multi-set
where you had some quantity
but for this super simple example let's
just pretend that you can add an item to
a cart only once
so what should the client do when they
get this
uh kind of set of possible contents of
the cart one of which is a cart
containing a book the other one is a
cart containing a blender good good
answer yeah
you could merge them together
to get just one
cart containing both items
in other words you take the union of the
two sets
this specific situation is actually
discussed in the dynamo paper about
taking the union of two shopping carts
so there's a lot more to say on this
topic
and i i hope i'll have time to talk
about it more
later on um but uh
this is kind of one of the topics that's
covered in the dynamo paper
but we have a whole lot of other stuff
that we want to do
so we're going to have to come back to
this later maybe
perhaps a little bit later in the course
because there's some kind of interesting
problems
to consider here so
another concept that will come up so
looking at
uh going back to our list of you know
concepts that you that will be useful to
you as you read the dynamo paper
um another concept that will be useful
is the concept of
network partitions
this is something that the paper will
expect you to know
what it means so let's talk about it oh
what does this term mean does anybody
know
ah so somebody suggested something in
chat about to come back to this previous
example
um somebody mentioned set intersection
what if you used that intersection here
instead of set union well the
intersection of the set containing the
book and the intersect
and the second containing the blender is
the empty set right
so you know ask yourself why
it might not make sense to use the the
set intersection instead of the
instead of the union but then
after you thought about that ask
yourself what situations could things go
wrong if you use the set union
so that's kind of an interesting thing
to think about too
okay so network partitions what does
this term mean
anyone know
right yeah so if you have some kind of
network
of communicating nodes
you can imagine a scenario where
some of them might not be able to talk
to each other
so you could imagine some situation
maybe where maybe machine
one and machine two can talk to each
other
um but maybe neither of them can reach
machine three
so there can't be any communication
between this side and this side
that's a network partition
you can also have bad situations where
you might have a client
who can connect to machines on both
sides
of a partition
but they can't connect to each other
and then rarely you might have a
situation where
side one can send messages to side two
but the messages get lost if uh going
the other way so side two can't send
messages back to side one so that's
also something that can occur so
basically network partitions are when
you when there's some subset of nodes in
the network
that cannot communicate with other nodes
in the network note that this is
don't confuse this with the concept of
um
of data partitioning so a network
partition is something bad
right this is generally thought to be a
bad thing
uh when parts of a network can't
communicate and data partitioning on the
other hand refers to
when you have more data than will fit on
one machine so you store some data on
one machine and some data on another and
you have to split it
and you have to make a decision about
what you put where um so that's
something that you do on purpose
whereas this is a failure that you have
to cope with
so network partitions are an unfortunate
fact of life
and conveniently we have a way to talk
about them using the fault models that
we already have
so we just use the omission fault model
and we say
that any messages that cross the
partition are considered lost messages
so we kind of already have a way of
talking about network partitions
but i want you to be aware of this term
because it's uh it's used in the dynamo
paper
and there's another piece of terminology
that i want to introduce
that the paper will use in fact it's
right in the title of the dynamo paper
so the
the paper claims that uh their system
is a highly available
key value store
the paper claims to be about a highly
available system right in the title so
what the heck does that mean what is
availability
any ideas
liveness yeah good
it is indeed a liveness property
we actually have seen
something that you could call
availability
so there was an exam question about this
where it mentioned this property of
every request receives a response
and the the question was asking what is
this property is it safety or liveness
this is an example of a liveness
property
so this would be a way to define
availability
this would be a way to define perfect
availability every request receives a
response this actually isn't a great
definition because
you probably you probably want more than
this right you probably also want the
responses to be fast
right you don't just want them to be you
know eventually received you probably
want them to be received within
you know some time limit uh or or maybe
you want you know
the at the 99.9 percentile
you want those to be received within
some time limit and a whole lot of the
dynamo paper is about that
but this is an okay starting point for
talking about availability
if every request receives a response
that's kind of like a baseline of what
you might hope for
okay so let's say that you're you're
trying to do some kind of replication
um let's say that it's primary backup
replication
which we've already talked about uh
provides strong consistency
so we have our client over here you know
in a couple of
replicas so let's say that we have our
primary and we have our backups
like so and let's say that the client
decides to do a write
but let's suppose that there's a network
partition
right here so the primary can't reach
the backups
what does the primary do does it
acknowledge the right to the client
what do you think
so think back to what what happens
normally during primary backup
replication right
if this network partition weren't there
then the primary would have to talk to
the backups
the backups would have to acknowledge
the primary and then the primary would
respond to the client
so here's the client she's sitting here
waiting
she doesn't know that there's a network
partition over here
what happens well
normally under primary backup
replication our primary couldn't
acknowledge the right because it would
have to write to all the backups
before uh acknowledging the client
right so what we would want would be for
these messages to go here
and for the backups to then respond to
the primary and then
for the acknowledgement to happen but it
can't do that
if there's a network partition so it
can't respond to the client
so that sucks
[Music]
what would be the alternative well the
alternative would be
for the primary to go ahead and
acknowledge the client
even though there's a partition here and
then you know right to the backups later
on
at whatever point the partition heals so
at some point hopefully you know this
partition will go away
and then the primary will be able to
send the update to the backups
that it had received but what would be
wrong with doing it that way
right so the whole point of doing this
replication right was supposed to be
uh having more than one copy of the data
right
so if we do it right here and then we
acknowledge it
and the primary is the only place where
that right is saved well the client was
probably hoping and interacting with
this replicated
kvs over here that once she
submitted a write and got it
acknowledged that that meant that the
data was in fact replicated but that's
not the case now our data
is only here in one place and we're just
hoping that this partition will heal
before the primary crashes right so if
the primary
were to crash at this point uh before
that
right has been replicated elsewhere then
the client's kind of out of luck
so so that's no good so the backups
would be inconsistent they disagree with
the primary
and if the primary crashes and a backup
has to take over
then the client wouldn't see this right
even though it's been acknowledged
to her so that's bad too
so neither approach is ideal right
in one of these situations if there's a
partition here
so this partition is the thing that's
causing all the the problem right
if we wait until the partition heals
and then finally acknowledge then the
client has to wait a long long time
right they have to wait some arbitrary
amount of time until the partition heals
if on the other hand we acknowledge the
right immediately
and then we just send the updates to the
backups later on as soon as we're able
then we might be giving the client bad
information
so unfortunately network partitions are
a fact of life
and so we have to make a choice between
these
these two rather unappealing options
so the choice that primary backup
replication makes
is to prioritize consistency at the
expense of availability
right if you send a right
and then there's a partition anywhere in
here
then you're not going to get a response
until that partition heals if it ever
heals
the choice that systems like dynamo make
is to prioritize availability at the
expense of consistency
and i can't tell you that either one of
these choices is better
right so you know it depends on your
needs it depends on the application
you can't have it both ways and that's
true regardless of the replication
strategy you're using so i could have
also said
a chain replication in here
and just more generally than this um
let's just say that you have two
replicas with a partition between them
let's say that you have two replicas
like r1 and r2
like this and let's say that there's a
network partition right here
and let's say that you have a client who
can talk to both
so this isn't a primary backup type
situation where there's only one primary
that the client can talk to
so that's not really the issue here the
issue is this so let's say that the
client
first decides to talk to replica one and
does a write
and has it acknowledged and let's say
that the client can also talk to this
side of the partition
right so this is one of those situations
where the client can talk to both but
they can't talk to each other
so now the client can make a query over
here
she's asking what x is maybe x thought
that
that x was four before
this is like that read your rights
situation that we talked about last time
so this client has done a right and now
she's trying to read her right
what is replica 2 supposed to do
well it could respond with x's 4
right which would violate consistency
because the client knows that she just
wrote uh
5 for x so this would violate
consistency
or another choice that replica 2 could
make would be
well i can't tell you what x is until i
talk to replica 1
because i need to make sure i know what
replica 1 thinks before i get back to
you
but it can't talk to replica 1 right now
so that would violate availability
so this is a fundamental trade-off no
if you want to prioritize availability
then sometimes you may get wrong answers
you may not be able to read your rights
if you want to prioritize consistency
then sometimes you're going to be
leaving clients hanging
so the choice that amazon made for
dynamo is that they want to prioritize
availability they're saying sometimes
it's okay to get answers that are a
little bit wrong
and that's a reasonable choice to make
in a lot of situations
any thoughts on that questions about
that
yeah so in chat somebody says accurate
information is more important
yeah for a lot of applications
absolutely so for a lot of applications
this situation where we're telling the
client something different than
what she thought is not okay
but for some applications it might be
fine
especially if once this partition heals
because network partitions hopefully
aren't forever
hopefully once this partition heals then
you know either replica 2 can go out and
proactively ask
the other replicas okay what do you
think should i update my value for x
and then it would get this update maybe
even see that it's causally before the
update that it had
and then be able to update itself or
replica one could
uh send its update to r2 after the
partition heals and then we would be
consistent eventually
right uh so that's an option
and some of the time that's fine other
times
we want to prefer this situation where
clients never get wrong information
and we would rather not respond at all
than give them wrong information
so that's what that's kind of the
dilemma that we're in uh with
availability and consistency
so there's a name for this trade-off
this famous trade-off
and it's called cap so it stands for
consistency
availability
partition tolerance
so cap stands for consistency
availability and partition tolerance and
then the idea of cap
is very simple it's just if you want to
be tolerant to network
partitions then you can't have both
perfect consistency
and perfect availability you have to
compromise a little bit one way or
another
uh cap is widely misunderstood uh
because some people interpret it to mean
something like
uh consistency availability and
partition tolerance pick two out of
three
so then people will say oh well i'll
pick consistency and availability
and then uh that's bad right because
partitions happen they're just a fact of
life like we said so you can't really
pick consistency and availability
you have to you have to have partition
tolerance it's not really something that
you can sacrifice
in a practical system way this gets
misunderstood is that people think that
this is kind of an all or nothing
trade-off like they might think
okay i'm gonna have uh
no availability at all and i'm gonna
have perfect consistency
or i'm gonna have perfect availability
and and no consistency so
that kind of doesn't make sense either
uh instead
you shouldn't think of this as sort of a
binary choice between one or the other
you should think of this as more just
like prioritizing one over another and
different systems might make different
choices of turning these dials
of consistency is more important
availability is less important
versus availability is more important
consistency is less important
uh so cap is widely misunderstood
um but this picture kind of sums it up i
mean it's not it's not really that hard
to understand
it's just that
you can't have it both ways of having
perfect consistency and perfect
availability and so like everything else
in distributed systems like i say every
day
it's a trade-off and you have to decide
what you want to prioritize
uh so the question chat is how do
network partitions heal
well um so there could be a network
partition like
so just just really um uh
i i always use the example in the class
of somebody yanking out a network cable
right so maybe that network cable
gets plugged back in and then our
network partition is healed
um or you know a backhoe took out uh
the fiber optic cable on my street right
um so those sorts of things
could be thought of as network
partitions
um but network partitions are kind of an
unavoidable fact of life
um and furthermore
you don't really have to think of this
network partition as being
a an either or thing like either the
network is partitioned or it's not
it could just be that messages are slow
right
as far as the client is concerned if
she's sitting here
waiting for a long time right like
if it takes days to get back the answer
to this query right
you know so that's kind of an extreme
example right it wouldn't actually
take days but um if it did
but then she got an answer like at the
end after several days
right that would be you know in
it that would be satisfying our
definition of availability that we gave
before that we said every request
receives a response
right but it's still it's it's um
it's not a very satisfactory
uh situation so
um so what we actually care about
is more like requests being satisfied
between
it within some reasonable amount of time
and you'll see this discussed a lot
in the amazon paper because they've done
a lot of thinking about
how to measure and how to
make sense of statistics about
availability and how long it takes to
satisfy requests and
they are aware of the fact
that sometimes it's going to be really
slow to respond to a request
the issue is can you make most of the
requests be fast and you can make design
choices in your system that prioritize
availability over consistency
to make it so most of the time things
are fine
okay so i think now would be a good time
to take our break
and do our quiz so
it's 4 24 right now so let's resume at 4
and i'll share the quiz
our quiz question for today
all right see you at 4 34.
oh sorry about that
okay should be fine now thanks
all right one minute warning
all right welcome back
so just to try to recap
uh things that you might
recognize as you read the dynamo paper
so we just talked about availability
and the cap trade-off
so that's a big one that you'll see in
the dynamo paper
you'll see the concept of network
partitions
also related to the above
you'll see the concept of eventual
consistency that we just talked about
and you'll see the concept of
resolving conflicts between replicas
in an application specific way
in other words
that thing that we talked about where
you might merge two copies of a shopping
cart
or rather where the data store might
hand two copies of the shopping cart to
a client and the client would merge
them together
so that's just an example of application
specific conflict resolution that's
particularly important to amazon you'll
see that talked about
what else um what else comes up in the
dyno paper well we'll talk about
it'll talk about vector clocks actually
which you've seen a ton of in this class
so dynamo uses vector clocks to give a
logical timestamp to events
so just
i know you haven't read the paper yet
but just uh just so you know what you're
getting into
um we just got done talking about you
know how
dynamo does this eventual consistency
and it tries to be highly available and
it's doing this conflict resolution so
what what what role do vector clocks
play in such a system
right we talked about how vector clocks
were for causal consistency
um but vector clocks uh
um are also useful in dynamo even though
dynamo doesn't promise causal
consistency so how are they being used
here well
in dynamo vector clocks are kind of the
first line of defense
for conflict resolution so if you had
two updates like this
and they weren't concurrent in other
words if they were ordered by vector
timestamps
then you wouldn't have to hand them both
to the client like this
so dynamo makes kind of its best effort
at not making the client do this sort of
conflict resolution so vector clocks
come into play there
but as we've discussed so many times
vector clocks don't resolve all
conflicts because some things are
concurrent some events are causally
independent or concurrent
so what does dynamo do when vector
clocks aren't enough it either lets the
client take care of that conflict
resolution with their own
conflict resolution mechanism that they
provide
or dynamo just says the last right wins
so these are all concepts that you'll
hear about in the paper
plus a lot more that we haven't talked
about yet
so there's going to be a bunch of stuff
in the paper that we have not yet
discussed
and we're going to be discussing that
stuff next time
after you've read the paper so enjoy it
i hope you got something out of it and
uh
um we'll be talking a lot more about
that additional stuff that we didn't
cover today next time okay
um there's one other thing that i wanted
to talk about today that i forgot to put
on the agenda
uh but it's pretty important so i do
want to talk about it
so as you're working on assignment three
um you're probably trying to think about
how to test your distributed system
so we gave you a test script right but
if you recall from the assignment spec
we say in the spec that the test script
that we provide
is not even close to being exhaustive
so we ask you to come up with your own
testing strategy on your own
as well and uh and you'll probably want
to
run additional tests aside from the ones
that that we offer
so i want to just talk for a second
about about testing and why testing
distributed systems is so
hard so let's just continue using read
your rights as an example because
that's that's something that we've been
talking about a lot and it's pretty easy
to understand
so let's say that you're a client you've
done a write
it's been acknowledged so here's our two
replicas
and then you do a read from another
replica
what would you do to try to ensure
that your key value store satisfies the
read your rights property how would you
test this
well i mean of course you want to make
sure that you get the the five
back here but
you'll get the five back if
replica one has gotten this right and
then broadcast it over here
right so if that write has gotten over
here to replica 2
by the time that the client then does
the read
later on then you'll be in good shape
right
so if that right gets there in time
there's no problem
the issue would be what if this right
was slower
what if this right landed here
and that would be the situation that you
want to guard against so in particular
if this write happens and then the
broadcast of the right is slow to get to
replica 2.
and then the client's uh
request lands over here if their read
request lands over here on replica 2
before the update has happened
what is replica 2 supposed to do well
one way to satisfy read your rights
would be for it to wait
until it gets the missing right
and then respond to the client so if
that's
what the choice that it made in this
latter situation where the message was
slow
then it would have to wait to respond to
the client and then respond to the
client a little bit later that's one way
to satisfy read your rights
you could also imagine it returning an
error
like a 500 server error saying
i am behind go talk to some other
replica
so those are both different ways
of satisfying read your rights one of
them is just you know wait for a while
until you get an answer another approach
is to respond right away
with an error saying go talk to somebody
else i don't know
right and then you could imagine a sort
of in between compromise where the
replica maybe has some sort of timeout
where they wait for a while to get that
update that they have seen is missing
they know an update is missing right
because the causal metadata that was
returned here
is going to come along in this next
request
so the replica is going to know that
they're waiting on a message they just
haven't gotten it yet
so they have a choice to make they can
just they can wait
um but they probably don't want to wait
indefinitely
but here's the issue when you're testing
your distributed system
you've got a bunch of containers that
are running locally that are
representing these different
nodes right those containers can
probably talk to each other pretty fast
right so this is what you're going to
have most of the time you're going to
have this top situation when you're
testing your system
most of the time your right is going to
land up here
you won't even ever encounter this
situation where this right is slow
so this probably won't even ever happen
to you
so how how can you make sure
that replica 2 will never do the wrong
thing
if this were slow in a production
setting how would you test that how
would you how would you try to make sure
that your code would do the right thing
in a production setting if this message
were slow
any thoughts on that
good yeah so you could artificially
delay talking to replica 2.
so this message right here you would be
taking this message
which would be fine in your testing
setting
and you would be artificially turning it
into this
you could artificially delay or drop
this message
in other words you could
intentionally insert faults
into your distributed system to try
to test its fault tolerance so doing
that has a name and it's called chaos
engineering
and i bring this up not to tell you that
you ought to be implementing
a whole chaos engineering framework when
you're working on assignment three
because that's a
heck of a lot of work and i'm not
telling you that you need to do that but
i am telling you that it is something
that you should be thinking about
because in a production system this is
exactly what you would need to do
in order to test in fact this is what
netflix is famous for doing
so netflix
helped popularize this term chaos
engineering
by doing it in production on their own
systems
so obviously netflix has a lot of
interesting distributed systems
challenges to solve
uh they're they're serving a lot of data
to a lot of people
and it needs to be fast so
they um so they they have this practice
in their engineering culture of doing
chaos engineering
of artificially inserting faults in it's
called fault injection
inject injecting faults into running
systems to see what
how those systems behave and to try to
surface
bad behavior of those systems
so this is something that has gotten
more popular
in the last uh ten years or so um
there have been books published about it
and so on and you can read articles
about it and so on
um so something that you
will find as you work on real world
distributed systems is that often
in order to find bugs in the first place
you will want to try to inject faults
and even in production systems sometimes
it takes a really
long time before something goes wrong
one of my friends was working on a
a causally consistent or a data store
that was supposed to be causally
consistent
and he was trying to get it to exhibit
some violation of causal consistency
and it took days of him injecting faults
just like this
trying to throw errors at it before he
could get it to actually exhibit a bug
so and that was that was with his uh
actually
focused effort of trying to do so right
so in practice it could be months or
years before
messages get interleaved in just the
right way that cause a bug to
to be exposed so this is something to
think about
when you're building distributed systems
if you're trying to build a fault
tolerant system like a replicated system
like this
replicated systems hide their hide their
faults
right or i should say fault tolerance
systems
systems that are supposedly fault
tolerant intentionally hide their bugs
so fault-tolerant systems can be
especially hard to debug
uh because they they try on purpose to
hide the faults from you
so you might not be able to see the bugs
unless you
make a point of delaying the messages
dropping the messages causing machines
to crash
basically injecting these faults on
purpose to try to see what goes wrong
and so i find this really interesting
and if you're interested in this um
you should look up my colleague peter
alvarez work
uh on uh what's called lineage driven
fault injection
uh so this is work that he published i
think in 2015 or so but it's been
uh he's continued this line of research
um
and done more and more work uh uh in
this vein
over the last uh six years so what this
is all about
is okay you can inject faults but you
have a whole lot of choices for what
kind of faults to inject right like if i
have a distributed system with a whole
lot of messages like this
which messages should i be delaying in
order to try to
expose any bugs that might be there
right which messages should i be
dropping
which machines should i be making crash
so there's a whole lot of choices
and there's a pretty big possibility
space to explore so you might not have
all the time in the world
so you might not want to try every
possible
combination of faults right you want to
find the bugs more quickly than that so
this work on
lineage driven fault injection or ldfi
is about exactly
that it's about trying to inject faults
in a strategic way
so that you find the bugs more quickly
so in particular trying to inject faults
in the places that are most likely
to cause bugs to be exposed
and his students have also done some
really great work on this
um in the in the last uh six years and
it's cool so i urge you to check it out
if you're interested
um but i mean even aside from that which
is like cutting edge research
um there's a whole lot of chaos
engineering stuff that's being put into
practice
uh right now today uh in industry
so even if you don't even you know look
into this
research stuff you should be aware that
chaos engineering exists when it's out
there
and it's one of the best approaches that
we have for
uh for making distributed systems robust
to failures
a question in chad does ks engineering
have anything to do with chaos theory
um i mean i think that it's
uh uh not particularly
and uh and you could probably draw some
sort of loose analogy
but um uh no i mean i think the the
it's called chaos engineering because
you can think of it as like
some sort of nasty little elf that's in
your system you know climbing around and
wreaking havoc
by dropping messages and crashing
machines and delaying messages
and so on so intentionally causing chaos
in order to try to make bugs uh bugs
that were there all the time the idea is
you're you're not trying to create bugs
where they weren't before you're trying
to expose the bugs
that are already there that were
latently there
uh so that you can see them uh and one
way to do that is to kind of
intentionally cause faults so that uh so
you can see just how fault tolerant your
system actually
is so that's something that you can
check out and read about on your own and
hopefully working on assignment three
has gotten you thinking about
these sorts of issues of testing and
you'll see that
the the testing that we're doing is is
really woefully insufficient
for trying to uh trying to make sure
that your system really is fault
tolerant and that it really is
that it really will respect these
properties like read your rights
uh in the event of messages being slow
and so forth
something to think about all right in
the last few minutes here we have a
little bit of extra time
so let's uh let's look at um
the uh the last few questions on the
start of course survey
that i that i haven't yet answered
because we have a few minutes left and
i don't want to throw any more
information at you today
all right let's start at the bottom
because i i don't think i've done these
yet okay so somebody asked
since you stream on twitch do you do any
gaming yourself oh you know i think i
already answered that one
i talked a little bit about games i play
with my three-year-old
um okay class is 5am in my timezone i'm
sorry
um i don't really have a great answer
for you for that one
in the first lecture you said you'd like
to solve problems with programming
languages
and i found it really interesting i'd
like to know how that you have reached
that idea and your research interests um
so i was always interested in pl and
my first programming language in college
was a functional programming language
racket
and i i fell in love with it and from
then on
uh i was kind of sad you know in the
middle part of my computer science
degree because i had to write boring
languages like java
but then i decided to go to grad school
in part because i wanted to get back to
doing that kind of functional
programming that i was doing really
early in my degree
so i'm one of those weirdos who likes
functional programming
it turns out that some ideas from
are deeply relevant to solving the kinds
of problems that we have
in distributed computing and parallel
computing and so
you know you'll see a little of that
actually when we read the next paper
that we'll read for this course which is
the mapreduce paper
um but i was interested just kind of
purely in programming languages at first
i didn't think any of this other stuff
was cool
and then later in my dissertation
or later in my in my phd work i um i
started kind of getting to know some
distributed systems people
and they actually came to me and told me
that my work had relevance to their
problems and i had no idea
so i really owe a great debt to the
distributed systems people who came to
me and told me hey what you're doing
actually has a lot to do with what we
care about
and this was at a time actually when
what i was working on was
i was having a hard time getting it
accepted in the programming languages
community because i
kept having papers rejected well finally
the programming languages community
started accepting my papers but then you
know by then i had already made friends
with the distributed systems people and
now i really i'm kind of in the
intersection of these two worlds and i
i like to solve distributed systems
problems with programming languages
solutions
and so i'm actually working with haskell
now and i work with a
really cool language called liquid
haskell
which it's kind of like haskell on
steroids that gives you even stronger
uh it can give you even
even stronger guarantees richer
guarantees about the behavior of your
code
so and you can use that for verifying
properties of distributed systems and
that's exactly what i've been working on
lately
um so that's me i guess that's sort of
that also
answers this next question here which is
i'd love to know more about your
research work
yeah come talk to me if you're
interested in any of that i would love
to talk about it with you
all right i think that's enough for
today it's 4 55
so i'll stop throwing uh ideas at you
i hope you enjoy the dynamo paper
and i will see you all next week enjoy
you